welcome back to this special edition of
Hannity now if you're having a Labor Day
party in New York City this weekend you
may have have some unwanted visitors
from above
the NYPD will be using drones to monitor
outdoor parties this Labor Day weekend
the department said the drones will help
officers determine the severity of noise
complaints so they know what to
prioritize over the busy weekend now the
move is predictably drawing backlash
from the community and raising concerns
over whether this violates police
surveillance laws
here now with reaction Fox News
contributors Leo Terrell and David Webb
gentlemen both thanks for being here Leo
uh you're an attorney you I mean real is
this civil liberties encroachment here
that you could be out there with your
friends make a little bit of noise it's
Labor Day weekend and the NYPD drones
above you
uh let me be very clear thanks for that
question Pete 30 years as a lawyer civil
rights lawyer there's no privacy privacy
concern these civil liberty attorneys
just shut up there's no expectation of
privacy above the in the sky it is
constitutionally legal and I'll tell you
right now it is effective not just for
Labor Day do it 24 7. you're in New York
City a crime capital of the country run
them 24 7. this is just talk expect to
hear systemic racism uh that is targeted
towards people of color that's a lot it
is constitutional legal P for these
drones have them 24 7 every day in New
York City I don't want to watch and meet
24 7. I uh David Leo's probably I'm sure
he's right he knows the Constitution and
and that better than I but really the
thought I'm in New York of this around
all the time I mean it's one thing to
monitor traffic or if you've got an
incident but if it's a party on a
holiday weekend doesn't that feel like a
bit much
yeah it is a bit much and Leo I think
you'll realize this cats versus United
States 1967. yeah you're not given that
expectation of privacy when you're out
in public how they get past the search
and seizure if they saw something
happening that might be up for debate
but let's look at where this is going to
be the landscape of New York City and
what you have to navigate as an operator
of a drone in any form whether you're
close by or using the camera building
Heights obstacles many other things and
then add to this the fact that doing
juver which is a very big celebration it
starts early in the morning later on in
the day it might get a little bit Rowdy
what if people start trying to take
drones down I'm being very practical
about this they're in areas where there
are people with illegal guns and what if
they start shooting what goes up must
come down and unfortunately I think
you've even seen this in La time to time
right New Year's Eve people do this
unfortunately I think they're they're
driving this bigger than it needs to be
rather than having on the ground
policing police officers who know the
neighborhood maybe know who the
troublemakers are can keep an eye out
they need to really think about this
another way Leo is this is this
basically the Drone flies collects in
information provides for probable cause
or Reasonable Suspicion and then you
could send uniform officers there that
the idea
that's exactly the idea let me tell my
best friend here Florida versus Riley is
a U.S Supreme Court case drones are
constitutional legal look it serves as a
deterrent it's a deter it's a warning
out there we don't want crime we don't
want shootings we don't want to solve we
don't want that and we're telling the
criminals who've been coddled in New
York we're going to watch you airspace
is public there's no expectation of
privacy so it serves as a great
deterrent and given the fact that we're
talking about New York City Case Closed
you need more help to support the police
in New York City they're they're
basically not supported and there's no
respect for law enforcement it provides
a step before the law enforcement goes
in there I applaud the police David last
word real quick are you going to have a
Labor Day party worthy of a drone
I'm going to have a Labor Day party
worthy of an American flag flying high
because you I and Leo we labor all week
long and we get it done but you know
Leo's right about the deterrent factors
and all of that but Leo you also know
this putting people in the crowd on the
ground you have an operator they're
already lacking police officers in New
York I think they need to find a balance
here but they do need to be careful of
the reaction that could come from the
crowd all right love you both have a
great Labor Day weekend thank you guys
all right unfortunately that's all the
time we have hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else